if you hold something sacred then your
team circles around it and it's only
those who circle around with you and
sometimes literally circle around like
Muslims at prayer in Mecca they
literally circle the kvass sir Graham is
a very primitive ancient it feels right
to circle something but maybe if even if
you do it symbolically or you all bow at
the same time that binds you together
children do that with their mothers when
they when they engage in exploratory
behavior right well they use their
mother as a center of the world and
children differ in the degree to which
they'll move outward from their mothers
so they move out until they they they
trip over there their uncertainty
threshold is it a distance it's a
distress and so so the more exploratory
kids who are lower negative emotion will
go out farther before they come back to
their mother so the mothers a center and
you know that that would be associated
symbolically with the idea of the center
as a mother land or potentially as a
father land that's right that makes
sense so this way that we're we are
incredibly symbolic creatures we're not
just out to make as much money as we can
we're symbolic and social creatures and
this psychology of sanctity or purity
has become really important not just on
the right it's always been important for
especially religious conservatives we're
beginning to see it even on the campus
left and this is why I think we see some
of the odd things we see on campus that
the campus must be kept as a sacred and
pure space one of the things that really
alarms me about what's happened on
campus the last couple years is that the
older idea we had that it's a place for
contesting ideas it's a it's a zone of
enormous choice people can take what
courses they want to say what they want
it's kind of a wonderful free-for-all
with some with norms of respect it's now
becoming much more of a religious zone
where the perimeter of the campus is the
the boundaries and within its if they're
almost there blasphemy laws basically
and I really started noticing this when
you look at the videos of the Middlebury
protests when Charles Murray spoke at
Middlebury and as everybody knows he was
shouted down so the students are
chanting and they're chanting in unison
and it seems like a religious revival
meeting and they're swaying and they're
saying they're sacred in a racist sexist
a charles murray go awaits like a ritual
incantation so that all i'm the state
the space is safe and it's safe it look
are not mature yet so far all this
happening is they're binding together
they're moving at you know synchronous
movement and call and response so it
it's using a lot of tropes from religion
and religious worship but here's the
cool thing when the administrator i
forget who it is comes on to say okay we
have moved we're moving the talk and
then you hear a couple people screaming
up off campus off campus and he says to
another location on campus and there's
like oh no no because you know look no
one had to go to this talk so everyone
could have just stayed home and the
students didn't succeed in shutting down
the venues they could have declared a
victory but it's not a full victory
unless he is physically off the campus
we can't have him speaking on campus
because that defiles us that pollutes us
we must shut that down and that's where
i started saying wow this is like
full-blown psychology of religion
durkheim sanctity purity blasphemy and
that i think you know that doesn't
describe most students that that
describes this sort of the core those
who really have their identities wrapped
up in this
[Music]